This DNews episode is brought to you by Domain.Com!
Deja vu: why do I feel like we’ve done this
episode before...
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and most,
if not all of us, have at some point or another,
experienced deja vu.
It’s that familiar feeling that you’ve
somehow experienced this moment before - and
even though a lot of people claim it has a
spiritual basis, perhaps linked to reincarnation
- there’s actually a number of scientific
theories as to why we experience it.
The term Deja vu - which translates to “already
seen” - was first coined in 1876 by French
philosopher Emile Boirac.
And in the years since then, researchers studying
the phenomenon - have come up with several
different types of deja vu that people experience.
In general, though - it’s lumped into one
of two categories.
There’s associative deja vu, which is the
most common type that’s usually experienced
by healthy people.
And then there’s biological deja vu - which
is almost exclusively experienced by people
with epilepsy.
Often times, they say it occurs immediately
before having a seizure.
And that medical basis actually makes it a
lot easier to study than associative deja
vu, which relies entirely on secondhand experiences.
For most of the 20th century, researchers
relied on the paramnesia theory to explain
deja vu.
It was an idea proposed by Sigmund Freud,
that said the phenomenon was likely caused
by repressed memories of a stressful event,
that people couldn’t access anymore, as
part of their regular memory.
It wasn’t until recently, when things like
brain imaging became standard, that real scientific
research - and not just speculation - was
poured into the subject.
Nowadays, it’s widely agreed that the medial
temporal lobe - the part of our brain involved
in conscious memory - plays a significant
role in deja vu.
This region happens to contain the hippocampus,
and more specifically, the parahippocampal
gyrus - which is what enables us to determine
what's familiar and what isn't.
Of course, knowing that this part of the brain
is related to deja vu - still doesn’t explain
why we experience it.
So in attempt to explain that, Dr. Alan Brown
from Duke University, concocted something
called the Cell Phone Theory, which revolves
around the idea of subliminal cues.
In his study, he showed a group of students
a series of photographs of various locations
- none of which they’d actually been to
- and then he asked them how familiar those
locations were.
Just beforehand, though, he flashed SOME of
the photos on a screen for 10-20 milliseconds
- which is just long enough for their brains
to register it, but not enough to actually
be consciously aware of what they saw.
Sure enough, the images that were subconsciously
flashed - appeared more familiar to the students,
than ones that weren’t.
And those findings, he argued, could be applied
to deja vu.
The idea being that whenever we feel like
we’ve seen or done something before, it’s
because we have - but during that prior experience,
our brains were distracted - allowing us to
subconsciously process that moment, without
actually remembering that we experienced it.
Seems solid enough, but that is just one theory,
of many.
There’s another one, called the Hologram
Theory, proposed by Dutch psychiatrist Hermon
Sno, that likens humans memories to holograms,
in the sense that our brains are capable of
constructing whole 3D images from smaller
fragments of other memories.
So for example, if we were to step into a
room that looks similar to a room we’ve
been in before - then our brains might reconstruct
an entire false scenario based around that
one memory fragment.
Again, an entirely plausible theory.
But there are some different ones out there
- like the Dual Processing theory - which
claims that past experiences actually have
nothing to do with deja vu, and instead, chalk
it up to a delayed neurological response.
The idea behind this one, is that because
there are multiple pathways through which
our brains process incoming information, it’s
possible that those pathways may not always
synchronize correctly.
So any delay between the time it takes for
our left brain hemisphere and our right brain
hemisphere to process information, could force
our brains to register something we’ve JUST
seen, as a previous memory.
Of course, like most areas of science, there’s
really no simple explanation as to why we
experience deja vu.
These are just three, of the hundreds of theories
out there - and of which seem equally plausible.
Still interesting to think about though!
And who knows, maybe you guys have some theories
of your own.
Or at the very least, interesting stories
to share.
If so, just leave em in the comments below,
and as always - thank you guys for watching!